Blizzard has confirmed tour beyond will
be the next overwatch character to
receive a rebalance the Swedish engineer
has been called out by gamers on the
overwatch subreddit as utterly ruining
this game on ps4 game director Jeff
Kaplan was quick to respond an outline
an upcoming nerf that will see the
damage done by 12 yawns turret reduced
by thirty percent the update will affect
console versions of the game only and
will be released mid to late july
depending on certification from sony and
microsoft the pc version will remain
unchanged torbjorn isn't the first
character to receive an adjustment since
/ Watchers release Western sharpshooter
McCree and femme fatale Widowmaker were
the first characters to be rebalanced in
an effort to make the competitive
shooter a little more fair McCree saw
the damage of his fan the hammer ult
reduced from 7245 as he was performing
too well against all targets making him
feel like a must pick in many situations
for the period of time before he starts
a reload had been buffed from point 75
2.3 seconds widow-makers widows kiss
alterna fire had its damage reduced from
15 to 12 along with the cost of her
ultimate infra sight increased by 10 the
developers cited she can often feel
unstoppable even when just landing body
shots instead of critical headshots and
that her ultimate was coming up a little
too frequently especially considering
its impact on the game for more on
overwatch any upcoming updates to the
game be sure to stay tuned to gamespot
you